من بين الاسلحه العديده التي تطالب به بها
اوكرانيا برزت دبابه ليوبارتو بقوه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه كمطلب اساسي بالنسبه الى
كياف لكن وصول هذه الدبابه الالمانيه الى
الجيش الاوكراني ربما لم يتم في ظل طماطل
برلين الحالي امتناع الماني تقابله دعوه
غربيه الى التراجع عن القرار وقد وجهت دول
البلطيق لاتفيا استونيا ليتوانيا دعوه
المشتركه الى المانيا لارسال دباباتها
الرئيسيه الى البلاد ما يزيد من الضغط على
برلين وقال اتقار رينكو فيتس وزير خارجيه
على تويتر ان وزراء خارجيه استونيا
واللافيا ولتانيا يدعمون المانيا لتزويد
اوكرانيا الان بدبابات 2 ايضا بولندا كان
لها موقف قوي بدوره اكد رئيس السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
انه من الضروري تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
وان سبب التاخير هو مراوغه المانيا برلين
وجدت نفسها اذا تحت الضغط بسبب دبابات
اليوبارد لكنها لا تزال متردده في موقفها
السبب نقلا عن وزير الدفاع الالماني
الجديد
بوريسبيستوريوس هو التفكير في النتائج
الوخيمه التي قد تنجم عن ارسال الدبابات
تتخوف المانيا فعلا من رد فعل روسيا ومن
امكانيه ان تعد ذلك تصعيدا في الحرب تتسبب
به المانيا مباشره رغم ازمه الدبابات فان
برلين جدد استعدادها لاستمرار تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا السؤال المطروح الان لماذا هذا
الاصرار الاوكراني على هذه الدبابه
الدبابه
هناك اسباب مختلفه تجعل من هذه الدبابه
الالمانيه الانسب للجيش الاوكراني في حربه
مع روسيا
دبابه اليوبارد هي الدبابه الاكثر
استخداما وانتشارا بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف الناتو ويوجد منها حاليا
اكثر من
2300 دبابه من مختلف الطرز قيد الاستخدام
لدى جيوشه هذه الدول ويمكن بسهوله نقلها
برا الى اوكرانيا فهذه الدبابه تستخدم
ذخائر حلف شمال الاطلسيه
وبالتالي يمكن الحصول على هذه الذخائر
بكميات مناسبه من اين من دول الحلف فضلا
عن ذلك فان الدبابه الامريكيه
ما يعني ان اوكرانيا بامكانها الاستعانه
بالولايات المتحده ايضا لتامين ذخيره وهنا
دعوات امريكيه نيابيه
ثاني اقوى دبابه في العالم بعد دبابات
ابرامز الامريكيه بحسب الخبراء العسكريه
لكن دبابه الرمز تحتاج الى وقود طائرات
فيما تحتاج اليوم بارد الى الديزل
لتشغيلها وتقتصد اكثر في مصروف الطاقه
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل الجدل المتوسط حول تسليم دبابات
متطوره الى اوكرانيا من عدمه هددت روسيا
اليوم على لسان النائب رئيس مجلس الامن
بظهور تحالف عسكري جديد من الدول التي
طالطها سياسات واشنطن
واتهمتفادف نائب رئيس مجلس الامن في
الاتحاد الروسي الغرب بالسعي لاضعاف روسيا
او تدميرها معتبرا ان تخصيص اسلحه ثقيله
لاوكرانيا لا يدعو مجالا للشك في ان اعداء
روسيا سيحاولون ارهاقها او ربما تدميرها
وهذا يدل على ان روسيا تتابع عن كثب
تطورات الدعم الغربيه لاوكرانيا على مستوى
الاسلحه بطبيعه الحال ومن دون شك فان
تاكيد حلفاء اوكرانيا على عزمهم مواصله
ارسال الاسلحه للجيش الاوكراني ما كان الا
ليثير حفيظه موسكو التي ردت بشكل صارم
والرد جاء عن طريق رئيس مجلس الدومه
الروسي فياتشيلا فولودين الذي هدد بالرد
باسلحه اقوى في حال زود الغرب اوكرانيا
باسلحه وشنت بهذا ضربات على الاراضي
الروسيه كما اضف رئيس مجلس الدمى الروسي
ان السياسيين الاجانب الذين يتخذون مثل
هذه القرارات يحتاجون الى فهم ان تزويد
النظام كيف باسلحه هجوميه يمكن ان ينتهي
بكارثه عالميه
مجلس الدومه الروسي وجه اصابع الاتهام
لاعضاء الكونجرس الامريكي ولنواب
الباندستعجل الماني والجمعيه الوطنيه
الفرنسيه والبرلمانات الاوروبيه الاخرى
فكل هذه المؤسسات الحديثه لاوكرانيا يجب
ان تدرك مسؤوليتها تجاه البشريه تقول
موسكو كما وجهت روسيا تحذيرا شديدا لهجه
لكل البلدان الحليفه لاوكرانيا في الحرب
حيث اكد مجلس الدومه ان تفوق التكنولوجيا
الاسلحه الروسيه سينتهي بماساه عالميه
ستدمر البلدان الداعمه لاوكرانيا
روسيا عادت مره اخرى للتلويح بالسلاح
النووي وهي النقطه التي تكررت بشكل واضح
في الفتره الاخيره فجلس الدومه اكد ان
الدول النوويه لم تواجه في السابق حال
التهديد لامن مواطنها وسلامه اراضيها وهو
ما تتعرض له روسيا حاليا في ظل الدعم
المستمر لاوكرانيا باسلحه قد تستخدمها في
مهاجمه العمق الروسي وليس فقط في
المواجهات على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي فان مجلس الدومه يرى ان حجج عدم
جواز استخدام اسلحه الدمار الشامل في
النزاعات لاغيه في ظل التهديد الذي تتعرض
له روسيا كان الكثير من القاده الروسي
البارزين قد ابرز مره اخرى قدرات روسيا
النوويه مشددين على ضروره اخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار في الصراع الدائر مع اوكرانيا